[Musique]
le mali scandale sensorielle ok c'est
peut-être un délire d'artistes ou alors
la vision d'un poète
peut-être les deux le mali scandale soit
sûr et c'est ce que j'ai ressenti quand
j'ai eu une prise de conscience par les
sens de la beauté de l'appartenance à
cette terre qui m'a vu naître
vous savez au mali nous vivons dans un
environnement riche en couleur en forme
en senteurs en saveurs en sonorités un
véritable au sens et à la créativité
alors si certains pays d'olt les
sous-sols sont riches sont qualifié de
scandale géologique - sans hésiter je
dis que le mali est un scandale
sensorielle en plus d'être une
parenthèse pas scandale géologique
il ya quelques années celle que vous
voyez de vote devant vous en ce moment
qui a du mal à contenir son émotion
était assise dans les shops de
revendeurs d'art et de souvenirs de
bamako j'étais assise quasiment sans
émotion était là j'accompagnais des amis
ou des amis d'amis des connaissances des
connaissances de connaissances qui
voulait qu'il ne voulait pas quitter le
mali sans avoir un souvenir et c'est une
forme de routine que je faisais dans le
sens du jazz dia mais qui ne gâte rien
s'il devait traduire le djatigui ya du
mali par le sens de l'hospitalité
je pense que jean le vrai un peu de sens
à notre khattiya je lui enlèverait de la
profondeur gens le vrai de la profondeur
à son sens pour illustrer le chat il ya
je vais juste prendre
comme base l'exemple de l'habitat
traditionnel que l'on voit très
généralement moi j'ai connu ça j'ai mes
grands-parents à ségou quant au mental
dans la demeure on a d'avoir accès à un
vestibule un vestibule le blue je vais
pas parler de toutes les spécificités du
plot mais j'ai parlé de son rôle dans le
quotidien on entre dans le blu il ya un
ou deux canaris qui sont toujours
remplis d'eau sous les canaris il ya des
noix de cola à terre quelque part il ya
une peau de vache souvent ou bien une
latte
ainsi le passant ou encore l'étranger
peut il sait qu'il peut entrer dans le
vestibule dans n'importe quelle
vestibule et là il aura à boire et s'ils
désirent se rêvait goret avec de la noix
de cola ou se requalifier il pourra
prendre de la cola et s'il a envie de
s'allonger parce qu'il est fatigué dans
la peau de vache et là où la natte
voilà un peu je commande illustre le
djia chez nous mais revenons un peu à ce
jour où je faisais budget attiyah
justement j'étais en train de faire mon
gentil gars avec mes hôtes
j'étais assise dans cette échoppe
j'avais je ne faisais très souvent mais
je voyais ça tellement souvent que je
faisais pas du tout attention
assise au loin j'ai entendu la voix de
notre cantatrice fanta damba qui émanait
d'une radio mais encore mieux jusque là
où j'étais assise les effluves tellement
attrayante
l'odeur atrium de payer 2000 vous vous
qui étaient vendus par une femme qui est
assise au coin arrivé à gonna ride
ça nous a tous donné envie en plus elle
les faisait frire dans du beurre de
karité à me voilà je réveille des
souvenirs
mais dont vous savez ce qui s'est passé
en moi se jouera si j'ai ouvert les yeux
j'ai regardé en fait j'avais les yeux
ouverts mais je voyais autrement et j'ai
vu dans cet espace confiné tellement
d'objets hétéroclites dans la boutique
du monsieur tellement d'objets mais je
me sentais bien et je me suis dit oh là
là je suis assise dans une véritable
caverne d'ali baba qui regroupe toute la
beauté la richesse des exemples toute la
beauté de la richesse que nous avons
chez nous au mali jeudi qu'un chance et
en plus se regarde et je vois des objets
de formes de couleurs d'usagé utilité de
matières différentes mais qui sont
agencés à la perfection pour donner une
forme d'harmonie et d'équilibré et je me
suis dit on est ce que ce monsieur
n'aurais pas pensé à une phrase que
j'avais souvent entendu dire par ma
maman est parmi ma grand mère quant à
notre arrivée qui disait un bébé ou un
bébé coup ci c'est pour
ces pages simplement souhaiter la
bienvenue car se serait enlevé de la
profondeur au sens de un bébé coup quand
on dit un bébé coup je vais essayer de
traduire ça en français j'aime les
néologismes des climats en avoir un bébé
coup ça veut dire que le spatiaux
spirito religion et économique au jour
graphique au temporel est suffisant pour
tous nous contenir et courut soir tous à
l'aise dedans
ainsi je me suis dit qu'il avait été
vraiment futé ce monsieur parce qu'il
aurait pu par exemple quand toutes les
tous les objets qu'ils avaient la même
forme ou la même couleur et les
regrouper comme ça peut-être mais il a
su pour chaque objet mettre en valeur
cet objet et l'autre qui est à côté de
lui nonobstant la matière la forme la
couleur et je suis revenu à quel chat
m'a fait penser aussi un des principes
fondamentaux de notre société
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait le monsieur pour
avoir l'harmonie d'abord il connaissait
chacun des objets il les connaissait il
les a acceptées dans sa boutique et là à
l'échelle humaine
j'ai dire que c'est la connaissance de
soi de ses propres limites
le temps b la connaissance de soi ses
propres limites qui m
ensuite le monsieur ils connaissent
aussi les autres objets la connaissance
de l'autre et son acceptation
on vient donc dans la tolérance et après
ils avaient sûrement une forme de vision
dont il avait la vision de quelque chose
de beau et pour que tout soit au mieux
il a utilisé quoi la complémentarité et
la complémentarité est un principe que
nous oublions trop souvent alors qu'il
pourrait régler tellement de choses chez
nous c'est une vue d'esprit de nos
ancêtres et qui a toujours fait ses
preuves le monsieur avec sa boutique il
aurait pu
par exemple couper tous les objets leur
donner la même taille
ou alors les peindre de la même couleur
ou alors leur donner la même forme non
il a respecté la taille la forme la
couleur de taux il les a mis ensemble de
manière de telle sorte que chacun
montrer la valeur de l'autre à cette
échoppe je vous dis pendant que je
ressentais ce petit cette prise de
conscience par les sens j'ai nommé le
scandale sensorielle en fait j'ai pris
conscience que je vivais dans un
scandale sensorielle parce que un
scandale censure elle venait de se
produire en moins ce jour là finalement
avec les autres ils ont fini ils ont
continué leur ils ont filé leur achat
nous avons fini par acheter des payé
2000 nous sommes régalés avec les uns et
les autres mais ce jour je pense que ma
vie a changé
j'ai appris à mieux me connaître pour
mieux me faire pour mieux m'accepter moi
même mieux connaître les autres
mieux les accepter pour une armée à pour
une harmonie de nous tous si j'avais un
message à passer aujourd'hui ce serait
vraiment si c'est par rapport à la
tradition de ne pas l'acheter parce que
la tribu la tradition elle évolue c'est
d'abord de la connaître parce que trop
souvent nous rejetons les choses parce
que nous les connaissons pas on la
connaît on s'y intéresse
il ya déjà ce coin et après sur le plan
humain on gagne beaucoup parce que si
nous sommes heureux si chacun d'entre
nous connaît ses capacités connais ses
ambitions à une vision globale
il ne pourra que s'intégrer de la
meilleure manière et sans déranger
je tiens avant de finir parce que quand
j'ai parlé de la vie de l'homme qui
auraient pu peindre et où on parle
beaucoup trop d'égalité l'égalité n'est
pas opposé à la complémentarité
les deux peuvent marcher ensemble mais
on est obligé camair de rester encore
sur ce côté de complémentarité qui
contient la tolérance la connaissance de
soi la connaissance de l'autre est pour
quelque chose de meilleur
je vous remercie je suis encore ému
[Applaudissements]